tout à fait les abaissances un peu plus
vous l'avez dit cette attaque serait
opérée serait fait au lendemain du
réveillon le premier janvier les
Ukrainiens qui s'attendaient à des
attaques de missiles sur la totalité de
leur territoire notamment sur kiffe ce
qui a été le cas et il aurait été il
serait il s'agirait en fait une réponse
en tout cas d'une volonté de d'affaiblir
le commandement russe du côté
ukrainien ce que l'on sait c'est que ce
sont des des lanceurs multiples Imar qui
aurait été utilisé si Rocket dont deux
intercepté par les Russes et quatre qui
auraient fait selon le commandement
russe une soixantaine de victimes alors
il y a toujours cette bataille des
chiffres d'à côté comme de l'autre
puisque les Ukrainiens revendiquent plus
de 400 hommes qui seraient morts à
l'occasion de cette attaque on ne sait
jamais vraiment combien exactement vous
souvenez peut-être de se croiser en
mosfaki a été abattu par les Ukrainiens
en avril à l'époque le commandement
russe avait admis une seule perte sur
plus de 4 un soldat qui était sur ce
navire donc évidemment du côté rue on
tente de minimiser et du côté des
Ukrainiens en tentent de de donner des
chiffres beaucoup plus importantes
toujours est-il que même si il
s'agissait seulement en deux une
soixantaine de soldats russes et bien il
s'agirait de la plus lourde perte lors
d'une seule attaque par les Ukrainiens
alors ce que l'on sait c'est que et bien
il y a vous l'avez dit de nombreux
critiques du côté russe et notamment
deux blogueurs qui affirment que et bien
ce centre de déploiement aurait été
repéré pourquoi parce que des conscrits
donc qui font partie de la mobilisation
partielle lancée par Vladimir Poutine à
la fin de l'été et bien c'est conscrit
aurait utilisé leur téléphone portable
et que c'est comme ça qu'ils auraient
été repérés alors ce qui est inédit
c'est vous l'avez dit la reconnaissance
par le commandement russe de et bien de
ses pertes mais également le fait que
l'armée ukrainienne revendique cette
attaque c'est très rare puisque hier il
y a également une attaque de drone du
côté russe cette fois au nord de la
frontière
ukrainienne à brillance et là bien pas
de reconnaissance officielle du
commandement
ukrainien tout juste se félicite de
cette attaque le gouverneur russe a
affirmé qu'un drone ukrainien a
endommagé une centrale électrique et
hier et bien au bout d'un œuf qui est à
la tête du renseignement militaire n'a
pas confiance elle est juste félicités
et interviewer par nos confrères des BBC
quand on lui a demandé s'il pensait que
ses attaques allaient se répéter un peu
plus sur le territoire russe il a dit
oui très sûrement et elles vont même
être de plus en plus fréquente et elles
vont aller de plus en plus loin sur le
territoire russe